hi guys scifi recapped here
before we start warning
spoilers ahead today i'm gonna explain a
2017 japanese samurai action movie
called blade of the immortal the movie
is adapted from a manga series of the
same name which focuses on an immortal
samurai named mongi hired by a young
orphan girl wren to avenge the death of
her parents
the movie begins with mongi a skilled
samurai on the run with his insane
sister maki whose husband manji killed
some time ago
when he is drinking water from a river a
mysterious old woman appears asking him
about his regret for having killed so
many people including maki's husband
maki suddenly disappears causing mongi
to cut off his conversation with the old
woman and find her she is held hostage
by a group of bounty hunters who are
after his head
mongi annihilates the entire group after
they fatally injure maki he is hurt
badly missing a hand and hopes to die
beside his sister's body
turns out the mysterious old woman
reappears introducing herself as yabby
cooney despite mongi's plea for her to
end his life she injects him with sacred
bloodworms that would treat his wounds
even reattaching his hand and causing
him to be ageless and immortal
fifty years later ito ryu a group of
master swordsmen led by anotsukaga hisa
is determined to conquer every single
dojo or martial arts academy in the
country
refusal to eato ryu's offer would lead
to the dojo members being slaughtered
kagahesa easily defeats master asano in
a quick duel and abducts his wife but
warns his men to not touch asano's
daughter rin who is just a young girl
rin is keen on learning sword fighting
despite her family's dismay
left alone in grief rin swears to avenge
her parents the yabi kuni appears before
her at her father's grave and suggests
she hire an immortal skilled samurai as
her bodyguard
she is determined and then goes a long
way to find him but mongi does not want
to work for her at first he does not
want to murder people anymore however he
pities rin and agrees to escort her back
home
along the way they encounter an ido ryu
member kuroy sabato who tortured and
took rin's mother he gives rin some of
her mother's hair and even shows her
decapitated head that he mounts on his
shoulder
rin is shocked as sabato prepares to
take her too manji shows up and defeats
him
sabato successfully strikes a fatal blow
at manji but due to his abilities mongi
can heal himself leaving rin in awe
mongi agrees to train rin and protects
her until she can avenge her parents
kagahisa talks with hibaki a government
representative about an agreement to put
ido ryu in the shogunate and make him
the head of the new martial arts academy
he then receives news of sabato's death
and is confused as he knows rin is not
that skilled to take down one of his
best assassins
meanwhile rin is sharpening mongi's
knives and daggers in the town market
when she notices a man using her
father's sword that man is tito magitsu
sent by kagaheeza to deal with kuroi's
murderers
mongi learns of him from wren and
quickly heads to challenge magitsu manji
wins the fight leaving magetsu badly
injured
after mistaking rin for maki rin finally
learns that she reminds mongi of his
deceased sister although he refuses to
talk further about it
the injured maguetsu receives treatment
at the ito ryu base and reports to
kagahisa that an immortal swordsman is
hired as rin's bodyguard
rin and manji travel to a village and
they stop by for a meal
manji is reading a map about every dojo
conquered by the ido ryu when another
ido ryu swordsman iku shitsuma posing as
a monk approaches him
he expresses that he would like mongi to
join him so they can defeat kagahisa
together
mongi denies the offer as his gut
feeling tells him that something is not
right
enraged shitsuma draws his sword then
they fight ruthlessly
turns out shitsuma is also immortal for
a longer period than mongi
he poisons his sword to weaken the
bloodworms and slows down mongi's
self-healing abilities
however mongi is determined to protect
rin despite his own wishes to end his
immortality so he defeats shitsuma later
at the town market mongi and ren
encounter makey another ido remember
although gaining the upper hand makey
could not bring herself to murder mongi
even though she has severed his limbs
she questions whether ido ryu's motives
are the right thing to do then she
observes rin standing up for mongi
although she is not as skilled as him
maki decides not to end their lives and
leaves
although slowly mongi can still recover
he scolds rin for defending himself
because she is not supposed to do that
he tells her to train alone as he has
something to do that day which is
visiting maki's grave
rin wanders alone then encounters
kagaheeza
she is surprised to find that he does
not attack her
he explains that he murdered her father
to avenge his grandfather kagaheez's
grandfather was banished from the dojo
led by rin's great-grandfather because
he used an axe which was considered an
outsider weapon and not fit for their
fighting style
arriving back at mongi's crib rin does
not tell him that he encountered
kagahisa and knew the truth about their
ancestors the next day rin and mongi
encounter mugai ryu another swordsman
clan after seeing one of its members
shira defeating another ido ryu member
shira brings them to mughai ryu's
hideout where they meet other members
they explain that they need to stay
hidden so that the ido will not realize
that they have two enemies then offer
manji and rin to join them to defeat ido
ryu together based on their spy
disguising himself as an ido ryu member
kagahisa will visit mount takao
they form a plan to attack him along his
way by dividing themselves into two
groups that will take different routes
manji rin and shira are grouped together
along the way they notice a mysterious
figure resembling kagahesa so they
prepare to attack him
shira strikes a blow to his face which
turns out to be a woman hired by the ido
ryu at the same time other ido ryu
members appear from behind the trees and
they realize that they have been trapped
manji and shira fight the ido ryu
members until they are all defeated
after that shira attempts to harass the
hired woman
rin stands up for her but shira easily
injures her
luckily before shira tries to do
anything with rin manji cuts off one of
his hands causing him to escape
manji realizes he cannot work with the
mughai ryu especially shira due to their
different principles back home mongi
treats rin's wounds and tells her his
full story he was ordered by a superior
to murder several men which turned out
to be the man who would have reported
his superior's crimes believing that he
worked for the wrong cause mongi
betrayed his superior and murdered him
and his bodyguards instead
turns out one of his bodyguards was
maki's husband his death greatly
affected her sending her into madness
then mongi took her under his care he
warns rin that if she stands up to
defend him again he will quit working
for her believing that she only caused
manji trouble rin runs away the next day
continuing her quest for revenge on her
own while manji is outside he is
approached by other members of the
mughai ryu who ask him where shira is
he explains he cannot continue working
with him anymore
they explain that they must defeat ido
ryu because they are facing death
sentences from the government after
realizing rin is gone manji frantically
goes after her
meanwhile kagahesa reaches mount takao
and meets with ibane kenchuy the head of
shinkaito ryu although he is warmly
welcomed he soon learns that they will
not join ido ryu disappointed he leaves
while his comrades back home celebrate a
supposedly successful deal turns out
habbaki has betrayed the ido ryu by
sending government swordsmen to capture
kagahisa and the ido ryu clan
the entire edo ryuklan is annihilated at
their base while kagahisa running from
the army encounters rin and takes no
interest in her as he is busy fighting
government swordsmen
rin has no choice but to follow him to
ensure her own safety kagaheeza and rin
reach an entire village full of an army
led by hibaki
rin screams at the army for not having
an honor by attacking kagahisa in an
uneven fight and urges the battle to be
a fair one-by-one sword fight habbaki
orders his men to silence rin
fortunately manji shows up and defeats
her attackers although he is confused as
to why rin does not get his revenge on
kagahisa already and seems like she is
protecting him instead
rin tells him that his duty now is to
defeat anyone who dares to attack her a
battle ensues between mongi rin and
kagahisa against hibaki and his men
mongi manages to survive despite being
badly injured and bleeding in many
places while kagaheeza fights seamlessly
sometime during the fight shira arrives
and abducts rin avenging manji for
severing one of his limbs
manji makes his way out of the battle to
encounter shira again
he tricks shira by giving up all his
swords and daggers but he conceals a
small dart that he uses to free rin from
shira's ties he then sends shira to his
death falling from a cliff
meanwhile maki also arrives at the
battle scene and helps kaguhisa she
senses gunpowder and positions herself
to block bullets from hitting kagahesa
sacrificing herself
he continues fighting until there is
only hibaki left
although weakened and heavily bleeding
kagaheeza still manages to chop off
hibaki's upper body he then encounters
manji and rin again thanking them for
keeping him alive against hibaki's men
now manji wants to continue fighting him
properly completing his quest to avenge
rin's parents
they fight ruthlessly but in the end
mongi wins he offers his last fatal blow
to rin so she can truly avenge his
parents but rin hesitates causing
kagaheeza to counter-attack her instead
luckily mongi positions himself in her
way taking the hit rin quickly stabs
kagaheeza right through the chest
after kagaheez's last breath rin cries
for mongi whom she thinks is dying
she cries that he does not fulfill his
promise to die after her
turns out manji is still alive despite
his bad wounds and replies to her that
she should call him big brother just
like maki did
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching